I'm Kate bachelder O'Dell I graduated
from Hillsdale in the class of 2013
and I'm an editorial writer for The Wall
Street Journal I spent a summer studying
Latin in England in high school and I
was writing my dad these emails about
what was going on and what I was up to
and he wrote back you could be a writer
and what you should do to be a writer is
to read and to write so it was just this
natural progression it was never this
aha moment if that makes sense and
Hillsdale was just a good fit for kind
of lining up that natural interest in
curiosity with some concrete
opportunities to write for the paper but
also do a lot of writing and coursework
I was the opinions editor of the
collegian which was a lot of fun it was
a very good education and how to work at
a newspaper meeting my husband at
Hillsdale has been one of my favorite
things about my experience because it's
so much a foundation of kind of the life
we share Hillsdale is also an education
and learning how to live with others
because it is being shipwrecked in rural
Michigan with 1,400 other people really
lean into those relationships and
friendships that are every bit as
formative and educational with some of
the more formal coursework I think
people think opinion writing is telling
people what you think about various
subjects the style of opinion writing
that we do at the journal is to report
the news and put it in an analytical
narrative
it's an institution it's more than 125
years old editorial pages in a sense you
are a steward of something that will
continue on long after you're done
working for it and so it's a taking care
of something it was really an exciting
wonderful honor to get this award
especially since so much of my life I
feel I owe to Hillsdale
almost silly to be receiving an award
from somebody and gave you everything
you have I'm honored but also just
amazed and kind of covered in gratitude
with it all
[Music]
you